[Music]
Merry Christmas Clara Godfather your
gift this year would be something you'll
never forget most people don't realize
there are troubled realms within our
world
[Music]
[Applause]
and you hold the cheese
to their secrets
remember Clara nothing is as it seems
where am I you're in the four realms
princess Clara that's your service or
Majesty
maybe I have been spending too much time
in the Attic welcome to our world
the land of snowflakes the land of
flowers and the land of sweets but in
the fourth round
this is where our troubles began
mother ginger started this war don't you
know it's dangerous here I hope you'll
be the one to finish it it's time to
save the kingdom physics do those laws
always work
Horace Heidt ready
she's gathering her forces you're the
only one who can stop her
I've been expecting you
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
this is your mother's through your grace
have you got to save us Clara No
I'm sorry I didn't even know this place
existed before today you see I was
looking for a Christmas present for my
godfather I love Christmas
what's Christmas and then I ran into
this horrible of mouse and that's why
I'm at the captain you barely escaped
mother ginger and the Mouse King you're
lucky to be alive you must promise never
to go back to the land of amusements
Clara its title has been rescinded huh
of course I meant the 4th rail many
apologies I'm just so upset ladies and
gentlemen my favorite part of Christmas
my favorite part of this evening I
present to you your gifts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like planets
like I said
[Music]
and the land sweets
[Music]
the first time I saw the Nutcracker I
was three it's an unbelievably beautiful
ballet so sort of magical stay alert
I'm not alert I'm scared I went to see
The Nutcracker at the National Ballet
with my family and I loved it The
Nutcracker was the very first ballet
that I ever performed then I was 13
years old and I had just started dancing
the ballet tells the story have the full
rounds how you'll know they discovered
Elwha watching it you're just captivated
by the dancers I remove every leaf and
lift that they do you kind of hold your
breath and then when it's over you're
like wow it's such a sort of perfect
Christmas story Christmas Eve it's going
to be a magical night this film takes
the story you love combining it with new
twists and turns mother ginger wants to
rule the roads the film bought into the
world so it has a much bigger fantasy
element to it
the future of the realms lies with you
you get taken away with the beauty and
the magic of the world there's just so
much there for everyone I'm going to fix
this for you help me
I really hope it becomes a beloved movie
that people want to watch every
Christmas don't you know it's dangerous
here it's time to see the kingdom the
Nutcracker and the four realms has got
all of those elements of the classic
story but this is a version of the
Nutcracker that is not a ballet this
film takes the story you love where the
twists and turns making this an epic
adventure this is a very high level of
craftsmanship in the film from the
costume designers to her makeup designer
to the props to the set design they've
been allowed to completely use their
imagination were mine welcome to the
forum the land of flowers sniffing
and the 4th round where our troubles
began one of the things that was nice
about this project was the ability to
search her in a child we had this really
exciting world who was extremely
original soldiers toys coming to life
mice the Mouse King you feel like you're
in one of the most beautiful palaces in
the world every single set is a piece of
art we have a wonderful Academy
award-winning costume designer Jenny
Beavan
all the detail in every little stitch
even things that you won't necessarily
see on camera it's there and it's
beautiful I never imagined I would be in
a film of this magnitude and it's really
just a dream come true to be a part of a
story that means so much to me when you
go and see the Nutcracker and the four
realms you get taken away with the
beauty and the magic of the world I'm
going to fix it
do you help me
[Music]
Christmas Eve time mystery
[Music]
expectations
who knows what might happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time has come
[Music]
there's one side of acting that I've
always loved and that's the costume side
style as brilliant Claire has many of
them looks like nothing I've ever seen
the real it just doesn't make sense to
me anymore
that's why I have to find me the
Victorian era is very beautiful and
comes across in the world we're creating
they provide some fantastic characters
to costuming the soldier look is my
favorite yes I felt hunts to put on the
other it's a very powerful that ready I
feel like you're walking bouquet
lyta dress is incredible I have never
seen or worn anything like that in my
life
you look like the daughter of a queen
[Music]
Disney's The Nutcracker and the four
realms takes the classic story and makes
you want to be lost in this crazy
imaginative place
melanda flower is this amazing all the
details all of the care that was put
into it
[Music]
moving from realm to realm you no matter
how many times you turn your head
there's something there for you to see I
think the most fun was shooting the
scene in the land of the sweets just
being here on this set it's so surreal
[Music]
and the fourth realm is the troubled
world the world that's fallen into evil
hand
mother changed is the one who began this
war
[Music]
I hope you'll be the one to finish hi
I'm misty Copeland and I play the
ballerina princess in Disney's The
Nutcracker and the four realms are you
ready
everyone knows the Nutcracker ballet
story but this new version of Clara and
her journey is just so different
[ __ ] what my favorite scene isn't
that was the steam Misty perform her
dance ballet tells the story have to
fall around how your mother discovered
oh wow there's more to it than meets the
eye
it's really just a dream come true then
that cracker is such a big part of my
art form at a time
let's go
[Music]